[Music]
hey guys welcome to Harry Potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing unicorn blood first of all
what is it that's pretty
self-explanatory blood from a unicorn
alright so it's blood but why would
someone drink it and what happens if you
drink it in the first book in film
Voldemort in his shadow-like state is
observed feasting on unicorn blood in
the Forbidden Forest
Harry observes from afar and is in
complete shock completely unaware of
what he is witnessing when Voldemort
begins to advance towards Harry he is
stopped in his tracks by forensic assent
or from the Forbidden Forest centur
colony he's able to successfully ward
off a very weak uh Voldemort and then
returns to Harry giving him an
explanation as to what it was he just
witnessed it is a monstrous thing to
slay a unicorn only one who has nothing
to lose and everything to gain would
commit such a crime the blood of a
unicorn will keep you alive even if you
are an inch from death but at a terrible
price what we can derive from this is
that unicorn blood is a surefire way to
stay alive even in your most damaged
state but that this life force does not
come without repercussions he continues
you have slain something pure and
defenseless to save yourself and you
will have but a half life a cursed life
from the moment the blood touches your
lips what this means is that despite the
blood keeping you alive your life will
never be the same you are now cursed
damned eternally to live a half life
plagued by darkness fortunately in
Baltimore's case this is a non-issue as
he is already so deeply entrenched in
darkness his previous experimentation
with the dark arts and Horcrux has far
exceeded the dark implications of
drinking unicorn blood you may wonder
why Voldemort even needed to drink
unicorn blood as his soul was safely
secured by the Horcruxes that he had
created and the reason for this is that
despite his soul being so secure his
physical form and life force were not
while Horcruxes are nearly
indestructible the physical forms that
Voldemort assumes are not subject to the
same laws of physiology that others face
would that being said I think it's safe
to say that Voldemort is free to drink
as much unicorn blood as he'd like but
for a regular Witcher wizard
steer clear unless you are content with
forever living a half life I hope you
guys enjoyed the video remember to leave
your video suggestions in the comment
below and throw a thumbs up if you
enjoyed this one until next time Harry
hi did you put on able to cope with the
fire
Dumbledore asked calmly
[Music]